Since Negan, played by Jeffrey Dean Morgan,
made his dramatic first appearance on AMC's
The Walking Dead, it has been obvious he's not
a good guy. Good guys don't generally introduce
themselves by decapitating two fan-favorite
characters in gruesome fashion. Sure, Jeffrey
Dean Morgan brings a certain rugged charisma
to the role, and his scenery-chewing dialogue
has long been a series highlight, but underneath
it all is a man that has killed out of cruelty,
sport, and personal gain. He's also, lest
we forget his many wives, a serial coercive
rapist. His Sanctuary was a brutal, totalitarian
regime governed by a carrot-and-stick system of
physical punishment and monetary reward. The whole
hierarchy was kept aloft by fear. Before Rick's
alliance of survivors took down the Saviors, their
society represented the most extreme extension of
a system based on the flawed premise that "might
makes right." So forgive us if we've always been
a little skeptical of the bat-man's "I did
it because the apocalypse" rationalization.
As The Walking Dead concludes its drawn-out
tenth season, fans have been treated to
a dedicated Negan episode that seems to
confirm the worst about Negan's character.
The cynics among the show’s viewership may have
already written Negan off as a violent sociopath,
but the latest "bonus" episode of season
10 pretty much confirms for the rest of
us that Negan had issues long before the
dead started climbing out of their graves
and munching on the living. Some people are
just wired wrong, and for Negan, the zombie
apocalypse served as more of an opportunity for
him to indulge his inner psycho, than a trigger.
The episode entitled "Here's Negan," based on
a side story from the comics that was published
in trade paperback under the same name, takes a
look at the character's origin story. The prequel
tale reveals what the man was like back when
Lucille (played here by Morgan's actual wife,
Hilarie Burton) was an actual woman, instead
of a baseball bat wrapped in barbed wire.
The verdict isn't great for the big guy in the
leather jacket. While Negan may still get his shot
at ultimate redemption on the show — his character
has one of the strangest, most bittersweet
endings in the source material, after all — this
episode proves that he was never a man to admire.
"Here's Negan" shows us a familiar side
of Negan in an unfamiliar environment.
The former Saviors kingpin had always
relied on the paper-thin justification that
the post-apocalyptic world of The Walking Dead
required a brutal hand to start arranging things
into a shape resembling the lines of civilization
once again. It's all there in the somewhat ironic
name of his group. The Saviors were saving people
from zombies and societal collapse — at least,
that's what Negan was telling himself and any
unfortunate captive who had to listen. Turns out,
Negan's anger issues and propensity to resort to
violence predate the appearance of the walkers.
In "Here's Negan," the problems all start while
he's enjoying a pleasant night out with his wife,
Lucille. When a belligerent man at the
bar talks over a special song of theirs,
Lucille asks the man to lower his voice. The man
proceeds to get in her face instead, and at that
moment, Negan loses his cool and attacks him.
Post scuffle, Negan is fired from his job as a
gym teacher at the local school, where the man's
kids attend. He is also sued, and Lucille then
has to pay for her aggressor's hospital bills,
because the beating Negan doled out was so severe.
The scene paints a portrait of how
Negan's malicious and vicious ways
come from a deep-rooted place in his past.
He's always been a little too quick to resort
to violence, which many of us already assumed.
One of the open character questions that the
series will have to grapple with as it approaches
its endgame is whether or not a man like Negan can
ever truly redeem himself. We've seen plenty of
redemption arcs over the last ten seasons of The
Walking Dead. In general, the stressful conditions
of the zombie apocalypse allow us to be generous
with characters who have done terrible things to
survive. Negan's a difficult case, though, just
because of the sheer scale of his wrongdoing.
Since his incarceration, Negan has made
some pretty bold attempts to prove that
he's reformed his ways. First, he refused to
escape, even when his cell was left open and
unattended. He also formed a bond with Judith,
even risking life and limb to save her
during one of Alexandria's most dire moments.
Then, he played a crucial (if violent) role
in helping bring down Alpha's Whisperers,
the most virulent threat to the survivors since
— well – Negan. Anyone who was starting to come
around, however, is going to have to rethink
that assessment after watching "Here's Negan."
Potential spoilers here, but in the comics,
Negan is one of the few characters who actually
survives to the final panel. In the final,
flashforward issue that follows an adult
Carl Grimes (deceased on the show), we get a
brief glimpse of Negan who has been living a
lonely life in exile — presumably since the
Whisperers arc concluded. The man may have
earned his freedom by acting in the interests
of the community, but he never fully redeems
himself. His isolated life is his ultimate
penance for crimes that can never be undone.
We'll have to wait for The Walking Dead's
final season to see if it takes Negan in a
similar direction, but the very fact that
the show adapted "Here's Negan" suggests
that someone on the creative team wanted to
remind us all that Negan's flaws run deep.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your favorite
TV shows and movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don’t miss a single one.